depuis deux ans maintenant c'est une
guerre mondiale devant absolument
réduire la pollution classiques en
particulier dans les océans pour les
déchets qui flottent plusieurs
initiatives comme celle de ocean cleanup
ce navire qui ratissent les maires pour
écumer la surface mais les ong et les
scientifiques craignent pour la faune
prise au piège en rouge sur cette photo
le problème doit donc aussi être traité
en amont les rivières se sont comme les
artères qui transportent les déchets
verts les océans
alors le jeune inventeur à inventer
autre chose
voici l'intercepteur une façon de fermer
le robinet à déchets des symboles works
un navire complètement autonome 100%
énergie solaire des boues et dirige le
plastique vers un tapis mécaniques
jusqu'à 100 tonnes peuvent être
collectées tous les jours et ensuite
débarqué au sol pour être recyclés mais
est-ce qu'il faudra arpenter toutes les
rivières du monde
l'organisme a fait ses calculs en
mesurant la quantité de plastique
déversés
paris sponsors for a free était cent
mille rivière serait responsable de 80%
de la pollution mondiale de plastique
rocher en clean up à l'intention de les
nettoyer d'ici les cinq prochaines
années deux navires sont pour l'instant
des poignets malaisie et en indonésie
le vietnam et la république dominicaine
sont les prochaines destinations de rêve
en quelque sorte ici mathieu prost radio
canada montréal